I'm a full-time stay-at-home mother
prior to this I had a career as a
collections manager for art museums my
job was literally to make sure that as
many objects as possible existed for as
long as possible in their physical or
digital space I love museums and they
bring a lot of value to my life and I
hope they will bring value to my
children's lives and my grandchildren's
lives but the line between grandmas
house which is stuffed to the rafters
with treasures for her grandchildren and
warehouses of museum collections is
starting to feel blurry to me I have no
idea if a when I will go back to work
outside the home or if I will return to
my previous career but I'm wondering
what your thoughts are on museums and
natural or cultural history collection
yeah the thing that she said Ryan was
one cannot know what wide value of
future generations
I think that's simply not true you can
know certain things aren't going to add
any value at all and the treasures at
Grandma's house quite often are a burden
on the future generation yeah one can
know what will burden the future
generations not not with everything but
if we can discern pretty quickly the the
junk from the essentials yeah and and
then that that middle ground
what is non-essential what are the
things that add value we can figure out
some of those things are actually junk
we're kidding ourselves when we think
all of these things now she used to be a
Traci used to be a collections manager
at a museum so for all intents and
purposes she was a a curator so I was
walking around last night just thinking
about curation versus collecting and I
think museums are actually the places
that that do it really well so what
makes a museum beautiful is the same
thing that that I had a piece of
sourdough bread recently mm-hmm and the
thing that makes that a piece of
sourdough bread delicious how'd that
make you feel sorry Oh John was what
yours I've got a health update later on
okay all right today so we'll do that
during right here right now segment but
a piece of sourdough bread a really good
piece sourdough bread
it's very light and airy yeah the thing
that makes it delicious
is that sort of negative space the airy
parts when you go to a museum it's wide
open and beautiful or architects call it
the negative space mm if you have a set
of columns the columns that are tall and
gorgeous because of the space in between
them the space in between the emptiness
are the parts that are just as important
as what is there physically I've
listened to a podcast with Rob Bell
recently he was talking about the
nothing is something with that negative
space that is actually part of of the
curation knowing what should be there
but then also what shouldn't be there
you and I have gone to a lot of museums
and we're out on tour right now and and
the ones that stand out the most are
tend to be sparse because that which is
meaningful is highlighted by the vast
emptiness around it yeah it's one of the
the reasons that I find tiny homes less
appealing to me personally I applaud
people who really like tiny homes and
get a lot of value from them but for me
part of the reason I don't own a lot of
things but I like having the the
negative space in my you know 900 square
foot home as opposed to having all that
those things in two hundred three
hundred square feet and crammed together
yeah I like the beauty the the
aesthetics and when I think about the
museums that have stood out most to me
whether it's in Des Moines or you go to
the LACMA or wherever are they getting
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah it's it's the
the museum buildings themselves are what
make those museums awesome for me they
have great collections as well yes but
you're absolutely right like every
single bit of detail in the Getty and
the one in Des Moines specifically every
single architectural detail is
considering the negative space it's
considering how the curation of art is
being presented how the collection of
art is waiting person yeah with with the
building and so I love what you just
said about about they have great
collections but if it was just the
collection imagine going to a storage
unit on the edge of town and Franklin
Ohio yeah and and all of a sudden in
there you have the Mona Lisa the Mona
Lisa you have a Picasso painting they
just stacked you amongst boxes of other
junk right yeah figurines and statues
and and you have junk in there with this
collection of beautiful art would that
art evoke the same feelings and emotions
no you'd be like that's beautiful but
why isn't it why aren't we treating it
appropriately
that's what curators do and so I wrote
down this thing last night
good curators CreateSpace collectors
just fill space hmm you could put that
as a minimal maximum podcast Sean it's
good man yeah no it's I totally agree
III was I was listening to a podcast
this this past week Jon Caramanica he's
the music critic for the New York Times
and he has a weekly podcast called the
pop cast and and this week they were
talking about merchandise and how some
merchandise has actually been arced over
the years like bands have have
incorporated not just like well we're
gonna sell as many t-shirts as possible
but we're gonna find a way to make this
part of the experience how can we create
sort of folk art and physical goods and
he actually has the best use I certainly
wouldn't call Jon Caramanica a
minimalist but is the best use I've ever
heard of as a storage locker he he has a
storage locker for he collects
merchandise now he doesn't do a good job
curating the merchandise fact that's one
of the jokes he was making with the guy
there's a store and I think in Soho
where they take these old vintage pieces
of merchandise and they treat it like
art and they sell these you know
t-shirts and old vinyls and and
and and these goods from decades past I
think there's a store that curates those
really well now Jonah Carroll maka has a
collection just sitting in a storage
locker and my argument would be and this
is applicable to Tracy is you're gonna
get far more value from the collection
if you're able to curate it
appropriately and that's why museums
stand out to us so much because they
don't just take all the art they have
access to and cram it into a room mm-hmm
that that doesn't feel like our that
doesn't feel like intentional use of the
space when you go somewhere like like
LACMA it feels like they're using that
space intentionally yeah it creates a
set of emotions they use the space to
make you feel something about the art
the space itself including the negative
space and he is part of the art
absolutely yeah I really appreciate
professional curators like Tracy I think
that the world needs professional
curators I am NOT a professional curator
so I leave the curating up to the
professionals I think that's an
important point an important important
point because Ryan we agree that a
museum curator I mean what that's one
out of every 1 million people as a
museum curator there aren't that many of
them let the professional curators
handle the curation of large collections
in the Library of Congress and already I
was doing it I would just hold on to
everything
right and there would be no curation it
would be just a hoard and then all we
need to do is curate our own spaces
absolutely then you know I mean just to
to Tracy's point like she is a
professional curator was was uh yeah
she's been on it for about a year but
what I'll say is that there is a
difference though between yes there is a
difference between one person or an
organization curating a collection of
things they have a collection that
they're curating and then you've got a
person who is a hoarder and there is a
there is a very big difference between
the two right you know as far as what
what adds value to the future
generations I was thinking about this
like I'm trying to think of an example
of something maybe a hundred years ago
that we wish we would have held on to
that we didn't hold on to I anything I'm
sure there's an exception no I'm sure
there's I'm sure there isn't yeah I'm
sure there's an answer but like all in
all man you're right like there there
isn't there isn't a way to to sit here
and guess what is gonna add add value to
the future generations but but if we if
we go at it with that attitude then I
mean it's just a slippery slope man like
absolutely everything we could find an
excuse for everything that optimize for
is an excuse yeah was the the art museum
was that in Tasmania where there was
like literally poop oh dude yeah I mean
this yeah it was so genius this dude
made a there are different stages to
digestion uh-huh so what he did is he
took baby poop mm-hmm and took flora
from baby poop he basically made this
machine that had the different stages of
digestion so he put food into the first
what would which would you know
represent like the stomach with the acid
and then he put the flora in there and
then it goes to these different stages
of the digestion tract and then it
eventually makes poop mm-hmm and yeah
dude it that I I love how that artist
just basically I think what he did is in
his head he was like I'm going to
literally make [ __ ] yes and I'm going to
make it art well there's a David Foster
Wallace short story called the suffering
Channel and it it takes part of the
story involves an artist who basically
turns his own feces into art and and
it's a beautiful metaphor for and
especially because it takes place in
August of 2001 like right and and the
the magazine that's covering him happens
to be in the Twin Towers and and it was
this perfect metaphor of life we're
spending our wasting our time talking
about [ __ ] literally yeah
and and when you know what's about to
happen to these people who were in the
Twin Towers like you're all these people
are going to die life is ephemeral
and we're so worried about [ __ ] yeah and
and that is exactly what is going on
with most of the stuff that we're we're
dealing with her we're holding her for
future generations
we had Ryan Delk on the podcast and he
was talking about how you can optimize
for almost anything you know you can say
well I better hold on to everything so I
have this optimal amount of stuff you
can scrutinize and it's important to
scrutinize and you know what you might
not be all you might not might not be
right all the time but back to the theme
so I'm from Peter Doran mmm-hmm I bet
you'll be just fine without him yeah and
I think that's the the thing to keep in
mind a few other things that I wrote
down well I was gonna say the one before
you before you go on to the next thought
the one thing that I will say that
frustrates me so bad is the libraries
that have been destroyed throughout
history so like Alexander the Great
destroyed Cleopatra's library with all
the information on how pyramids were
built and just collections of books so
there are there is certain bits of
information that we do need to hold on
to now we can store those digitally we
don't have to have physical books right
but there certainly are there is
definitely information that we need to
pass on thee like the Aztecs they built
like [ __ ] chanita they don't understand
how they were able to precisely measure
when it comes to acoustics to make the
acoustics the way that they were I mean
there's a certain point where there's a
I figure what the game is called but
there's a field that they play this game
on and it's about 200 yards long and
literally I could stand at one end you
stand at the other and then I could just
talk like this yeah and like you would
be able to hear me whispering right and
all that information is lost because of
basically you know Christians coming
through and this stuff's pagan we're
getting rid of it right so so you know
just just to the point of like there are
things that we do want to pass down from
generation to generation to me I think
knowledge like that is something that
might be missed that I can't think of
anything else but knowledge is
definitely something that we want to
keep intact and that knowledge is not
necessarily a result of the physical
artifacts back then that was they'll
know where we had to capture the
information right now we have ways of
capturing information
whether it is physical or digital that
we can pass on and we can make we can
make redundancies I mean even we do this
podcast you know sean has certain
redundancy set up or with our website we
have redundancies set up so if it gets
if it gets deleted yet we make sure
there's some sort of redundancy I with
my photos that I scanned with the
scanning party it's in the cloud but I
also have a hard drive I don't have a
physical copy of them anymore but I have
several redundancy so I can pass that
information those zeros and ones right
on in the future if I want to I think
it's important to digitize whenever we
can we can take photos of things that we
want to preserve the those triggers for
memories yeah if we want to preserve
those photos is taking a photo is a
great way to do it but you don't need to
hold on to the the large artifact in
order to do that but here's the thing
when you curate all of those things when
it's grandma's home full of all this
excess if you kept just the things that
that were that we found to be most
meaningful we'll talk about how things
themselves don't have intrinsic meaning
but but if we if we we get more value
from having fewer things and if we water
them down with a hoarders existence yeah
and so we need to trust the curators who
are professional curators to curate the
museum's or the libraries but then we
need to trust ourselves to curate our
own spaces in our own homes and our own
things and I wrote this down here I I
wrote down that that the curators are
important otherwise anyone could put art
in a museum imagine if you could just go
to lack of money so I know I drew this
painting I'm just gonna put it up on the
wall here Thanks he totally did that
don't forget what museum but there are
people who have done it but you know
when you go to like a Panera Bread or
something I've got that community quark
board this is junk everywhere all over
the court oh yeah it almost like
indiscernible like you look at it you
don't you you want to turn away from it
because it's so distracting and so
overwhelming that's because it has not
been professionally curated anyone can
put some sort of notice up there yo
check out my band or check out this
movie or whatever it is and there are
other places like the whole food local
Whole Foods where you have to like hand
them the poster they have to approve it
and then they put it up and as I'm
waiting in line at the bathroom a Whole
Foods I always check that out because
there's like a few things there and like
oh I didn't realize that movie was
coming out or or whatever and it's
because those are things that they've
approved they've curated it but if it
was if it was just the the corkboard
where anyone could post something to it
then all of a sudden it's like oh this
isn't curated I'm just gonna turn away
from them because it's overwhelming
right and that's where we've gotten with
our stuff we are overwhelmed with our
stuff and the way to become less
overwhelm less anxious is to well it's
the cure rate right so so this thing
that Seth Godin talked about in his
podcast recently said without curation
there is a race to the bottom now I
think about YouTube which we're on right
now or Amazon Kindle books which were on
as well they've enabled us to reach a
large audience of people we're in the
top 1% of all Kindle books so we're in
the top 1% of all YouTube channels even
though we don't even have that many
YouTube followers but because anyone can
start a YouTube channel soon there are
plenty of people with one subscriber or
two subscribers or 100 subscribers or
whatever and and so the barrier of entry
is functionally zero right it's next to
zero I should say there's a small
barrier of entry you have to figure out
to use a computer and stuff but pretty
much anyone can start their own YouTube
book right you don't need permission
from like ABC or NBC those used to be
like in order to have a TV show and have
a show you needed one of those three
networks right and then there's a fourth
network that came along and oh my
goodness now we have 33% more content
yeah and now it's unlimited content
right it's and and it would be
impossible to consume all the content
that's out there and yeah in a lifetime
yes single lifetime absolutely and in
fact I think there's what a lifetime of
videos posted every hour on
I mean it's unbelievable yeah so there's
so much out there and so there is a race
to the bottom meaning there's a lot of
junk out there there's a lot of uh you
know what's some junk that's on YouTube
Jordan fouseytube
I mean every cat video but here so cat
videos or or fouseytube
I mean phousi has over 10 million
followers on YouTube so it obviously
adds value to some people right but it's
it's not so we have different types of
curation on YouTube it's not the
traditional curation something Amazon
when our audience goes and buys our
books it starts to recommend them if you
like this book you also like this book
and and people are able to rate them a
certain way same with YouTube more
comments or or more shares there's an
algorithm that YouTube will use so if
you comment on this video or if you
share it with other people then YouTube
if you thumbs up it then then YouTube
will say or if you subscribe to the
channel even right
the YouTube will say well we'll put that
into the algorithm some more people will
have exposure to this right and so there
is even a type of curation there even
though there's functionally unlimited
videos you're not gonna have access to
most of them yeah you're not gonna find
them unless you're searching for it
specifically right right and so there is
a different type of curation that's
happening there there is an unlimited
amount of stuff there just like you go
to a grocery store you have on a
functional unlimited amount of food
there but you can find the things that
you're going to want to eat and you can
leave the store with just those you
don't have to eat everything in the
store and so I guess the thing I would
say to Tracy to sum this all up is you
understand what you want and let go of
the rest and what I mean by one is like
what's what's going to add value to your
life what's gonna add value to your
kid's life and then what's gonna burden
them as well I can give you the advice
what's gonna add vitae my life or what's
gonna add value to Ryan's life but it's
not about what would Ryan do it's about
what would Tracy do what would Sarah do
what would Jim do what would Jeff do
whoever's listening to this what would
you do what's appropriate for you
because
what's appropriate for you may not be
appropriate for me and vice versa so
what do you want and once you figure
that out it becomes so much easier once
you get clear on the things that are
gonna add value to your life it becomes
clear that the rest of those things are
just a burden and when something's a
burden it's so much easier to let go of
it because it's in the way of a more
meaningful life absolutely
you